what up what up your boy twister right
here i want you to check me out on the
bootleg calf podcast
know that
all right look bullet cab podcast bullet
cap show we got a legend
i don't say that lightly twist this here
and i appreciate that
you're [ __ ] legend bro appreciate it
hey man listen
i just want to say i've been trying i
feel like i've been dming you probably
for about six months trying to be like
yo when you come to la man like it's
been a while man i know we always like
trying to lock in i'm glad yeah then
when i was at the radio station i mean i
probably been dming you longer than that
because we was trying to get you on at
the radio station and [ __ ] and
yeah it's it's good to have you here
though bro oh man man it's a
hey better late than never right 100 man
100 you have so much
um just historical legacy in the game
bro
yeah man you know what i'm saying in a
long time
um let's start like obviously
i remember i first heard you probably
it was probably around like 99
when i was like a kid okay and you
already you know
moving and shaking but it was it was a i
i think the first
song i probably ever heard you on really
was probably pope pimp probably pope
pimp right
yeah and then digging into all the other
[ __ ] the speeding up mobsters and all
that you know what i'm saying so like um
during that era in chicago hip-hop this
was before the drill [ __ ]
i felt like it was like what you were
doing what crucial conflict was doing
then on the other side of the token it
was like common sense
and the resurrection and you know and
there was so effect it always just felt
like chicago has always kind of been
two sides sonically at all times it was
like like
south side west side you know you had to
you know shout to the north side too but
you know mostly like a south side west
side thing
not really intuit with each other but
just
you know two different vibes a little
bit when it came to music
yeah what what is it that inspired you
to rap the way you rap
originally because you um
you know i always have this talk with uh
with with the homie ritz
um that when it comes to the like tech
nine two we've talked about you a lot
when it comes to chopping
there's nobody who can uh
really like you like when you rap it's
so clean
some people can rap fast but it's really
hard to understand like you enunciate so
perfectly every single like
it's it's like to me that's what it's
about that that's
that's the limit of it is is how clear
can you say your words at a certain
pace okay you know so to me that's what
it's about
it's a complete package and once once
one is
over the other one then you're not
really doing it the right way but when
did you start to master that like what
and what were the influences that kind
of made you decide to start rapping that
way
this was early on just really because i
was doing so many um
so many rhymes where i'm having punch
lines and stuff like that and like
more into battles like the younger stage
you know
and i wanted to sound different make
something different
right make a song or just a new flow
right so i started like changing up the
flow and making different patterns and
then
every once in a while you were uh you
know uh coming up the street and not be
backing into the beat
yeah and then just a little more than a
little more and then you start to hear
a few other rappers doing it here and
there you know oh man
and then one day i just decided i want
to make a whole song like that
i'm like i always make little phrases
like that let me make a whole song like
that
you know then i started making songs
like mr tongue twisters
mm-hmm that's crazy so
what year what year was mr tongue
twister man a long time ago
91 or something like that 91 yeah that's
so crazy you know it's crazy too because
i think it was 91.
i was i was four
[Laughter]
no but hey what's crazy is uh
like i remember as a kid like uh
there was like this um this
i don't know if it was a beef or a weird
energy between
you boys in chicago and the bone thugs
guys
it was kind of like i think they might
have said something on art of war
yeah i think it was art of war right it
was on that album
like all of the all the the early
early rappers that that had that style
at some
form or or or time
got out their body a little bit right
yeah yeah because it was like no you
bite me you bite me well
i was doing it first yeah we all got out
of our body a little bit you know about
that type of stuff so that was that was
early on when uh you know we all were
trying to stake claim at a certain vibe
not realizing that we were all the
founders of a certain sound
facts people well you know once we
started to realize how many uh
people we influenced then that's when we
realized that we were all brothers in a
sense who who who said something first
back then like who took the first so you
were the first okay so it was you first
yeah yeah i think i kicked it off first
i think i saw a crazy bone
when we was doing a video for
spit your game okay yeah i remember yo
that's crazy yeah because years later
you guys end up working on that together
yeah yeah yeah shout out to big man yeah
shout out to crazy
you know all of them are guys though you
know yeah that's dope yeah yeah it's
crazy because we think about like how
rap beef is now it's like it's not a lot
of maturing and getting past it anymore
you know what i'm saying
yeah you know uh and then then there is
some you know so hopefully
hopefully a lot of the younger cats look
at
the way we moved a little bit and kind
of kind of follow suit you know
when did you realize um that you had
something
like because we i think every rapper has
a you know whether it's
back then getting your demo in the right
person's hand or hearing your record on
the radio or
when was the first instance where you
realized like oh i could really like
make real money off this rap [ __ ] man
i probably can't remember the first the
first
probably entering entering a
contest back then you know because this
was how i first got on it's like
just getting in contests and stuff like
that so i think it was um
um maybe me and my guy cree getting in
the show
uh one day or should i say a contest and
did a song
and got the opportunity to record more
you know once people started paying for
stuff right once you saw people paid
money for to see me yeah people would
pay to see a show or something like that
you know things like that yeah
yeah that's that's wow so um you ended
up putting out
adrenaline rush uh
you were kind of like a i don't want to
call you an underground favorite but you
were kind of like a
you had like a dope cult following in
hip-hop
i remember when the uh
paid in full soundtrack slash
rockefeller album came out it was like
it was like a double disc album
and that was the first time that i it
was the we are the champions record
yeah and the way the way dame brought
you in on that record
was so legendary and you just came
you caught a [ __ ] body and i think i
might have saw it was like maybe a video
you or something in chicago getting the
rockefeller chain put on you
uh it wasn't chicago it was somewhere it
was on stage though right yeah it was on
stage
yeah yeah it was that was that was a
dope vibe right there shout out to the
homie dane
yeah how did um talk about how your
relationship with rockefeller started
um just early on a little bit of
everything
uh i would say kanye dame and jay
aw in some form or fashion just just has
something to do with me being involved
with rockefeller of course
jay you know with him being who he is
and us doing what we did with like uh
you know uh is that your chick popping
tags right
like that and then of course
yay having that vibe and bringing me
bringing me along in that whole vibe and
then
even with that vibe with like dang with
the with the champion's joint so yeah
that [ __ ] was crazy
everybody i was cool with all of them
was uh did you have a relationship with
kanye first because of the chicago [ __ ]
or did you guys not really
like have a relationship outside but
before he became kanye west per se
oh we was already cool he was already
cool yeah yeah we didn't kick it a lot
or nothing like that but we always was
around each other
especially on the music scene you know
in chicago so so
yeah it was cool yeah it's crazy because
you mentioned is that your chick and
and um popping tags those are some crazy
joints
crazy features is that your chick is
like i think that's one of those records
that gets forgotten in hip-hop you know
what i'm saying like we forgot we're
rocking that joint that joint is [ __ ]
with them
rocking them oh that [ __ ] is a classic
man that's my joint i think it's the
hardest memphis bleak record
that [ __ ] okay shout out to i mean shout
out to bleak but that's
yeah shout out to the homie um so
who so originally what made you decide
to go to rock i mean obviously at the
time it probably wasn't hard to make the
rockefeller decision because it's the
hardest crew in hip-hop at the moment
right yeah yeah we was rocking yeah
yeah i was loving it you know that whole
vibe to be around that team at that time
period was definitely a
a plus you know and then to be vibing
with them
was a whole nother thing so so it was
cool yeah what was um
give me like a rockefeller story man one
that like just being being around that
era being around hove during that time
something that we
like people might not know just like a
crazy experience that you had back then
um just always
uh weirded out at jay's prediction
ability
how he would look up and say you know
that slow jams was gonna be a hit
and then it would happen and then like
me
writing is this the end that song with
uh p
diddy yeah and and when i did that song
and and walking in the room with
jmp diddy chopping it up and we were
talking we started talking about the is
this the end joint
and i remember how how i was doing that
joint
i was faded right in that joint you know
so like real faded right
right and i had some good weed that i
never had before
so i wrote that joint and everything so
he was in there talking about it and
jake was looking at him and he just
looked and said
he was he was high when you wrote that
one so it was just but
it was strange because i was real high
when i wrote that so
for some reason about the flow he knew i
was high
the origin of the slow jams is a record
that i distinctly remember
like being in high school and and that
being like
my favorite record you know that was a
record that was
it was early kanye as far as you know
that was like one of kanye's early
earliest records yeah i feel like it was
like through the wire and then that came
and and i just kind of added to his
allure and that was really
that was really like was that like your
first hit record as far as like radio
like solo
radio level yeah yeah that was that was
like the biggest record of my career
hands down yeah overnight celebrity was
nice too though
man that was that was the joint you know
that was something to have to come with
yeah after the whole the vibe of that
you know so i i got lucky being able to
come with that one and
and him going as hard on the beat as he
was able to oh that bit was crazy
now but slow jams tell us about that
record how was it made like what were
the origins of that record like
like like slow jams was something that
was a vibe that
uh yay already had he already just
just had the whole aura of it he had the
beat
he had an idea of what he wanted me to
do so you know me
obviously knowing what i'm hearing is
like
like dope as hell you know not not
knowing it was gonna be that [ __ ] big
but i'm not i'm like man i gotta body
this
so i'm doing my thing on it but then he
put jamie on it and the way it all came
together
and that was like right that was like
peak jamie as an artist too
or really i feel like that is what
really kind of kicked off people taking
jamie serious as a singer
yeah it was that song that song was
because that was before unpredictable
that was before that his album so that
that was like the very first time that
we were like
oh jamie foxx could sing yeah that's
what turned it on to me for his music
career he always was talented doing
music of course
of course that record coming out like
turned it on and launched that
opportunity
and you say jay called that record he
called it he knew it was going to be a
hit
yeah he called it yeah when you were
around yay early did
did he i mean because i always tell
people who aren't like real hardcore
kanye fans is kanye's always been
oh you some water or something is there
some water in there
um i always tell people who who haven't
followed kanye west until recently or
the last 10 years that like honey has
always been a very uh
confident dude yeah you know what i'm
saying yeah like i don't think i mean
it's obviously magnified a lot you know
but i feel like connie has always kind
of been
a a mad scientist yeah
for sure mad [ __ ] scientist right
yeah
yeah like working with him because you
were working with him
that was before college dropout right
yeah that was slow jams was before
college dropout
before that released yeah you know i
already had a vibe of
of how he worked and and just what he do
because i was around him
when he was making beats early on you
know so i would
i would always know that his sound was
very unique
his choice of music was like a like a dj
almost
like a you know it felt like a dj i was
like man he knows his records you know
so yeah yeah he was always dope to me um
talk about too cam'ron so cam has always
paid homage to the shy he used to live
there yeah
he on on purple haze he redid adrenaline
rush
and you you caught a [ __ ] body on
that um
what is it about cam in chicago and like
just the homage and the respect he's
always shown man
it's been i mean it's been dope to see
over over the last however many years
i just feel like you know it's an old
saying where they say real recognize
real
you know and i just think uh you know
the vibes relate you know
like like like where he from and how he
get down
and shy town people and how they get
down and then just
cam being the person that moved around
no he was in ohio
at one point children doing his thing
too like chicago as well as other places
so
um him being a fan of my music as well
me being a fan of his music it was real
dope when he came because he was in
chicago
and we actually sat right there in each
other's face and talked about doing that
record so
he did he come to you and and when he
when he came to you was he like
yo i want to remake this for purple hey
yeah he had it mastermind already he
knew exactly what the [ __ ] he wanted
yeah so that's what made that record so
fun was because he knew exactly how he
wanted it that's wild
yo let me ask you this with kamikaze
being
a classic record right that was your
only album on rockefeller
i didn't actually have an album so that
album wasn't so what was your situation
with them
because you had the chain on you had the
features you you know
that it was it was it was pretty much
more like a family vibe okay okay okay
that we could have took further but at
the time i was on atlantic records right
i knew the album came out to atlantic i
didn't know if rock
so so it didn't so you technically never
dropped an album
through rockefeller yeah damn that's
crazy
so that was just some family ties [ __ ]
like hey you're part of the gang here's
the change
you know what i'm saying like definitely
that was far as far as we could take it
we would have took it further if
if the companies could have merged
merged the situation but
you know unfortunately that couldn't
happen so i had to
give it out keep it moving keep it
moving who was who who were you closest
with on the roster because there was
such a
a large roster of artists but you know
talking about the young guns we talked
about all the state property beans
memphis like
who who was like your your closest
comrade on the rockefeller
roster everybody was cool i had a vibe
with everybody i probably kicked it the
most with with uh
bleak and freeway freeway's a good dude
man
those are two people i probably kicked
it with the most shouts to free
it's crazy to see um the evolution
of what you guys started in the 90s with
chopping and
and rapping that way there's so many
dope
artists who do it now um
the you know the logics of the world we
mention ritz we you know obviously
tech nines are og tex tech and can get
in that bag
who are some artists that that you
respect what they do when it comes to
chopping like that
um damn who's that i was talking about
the other day
um damn
oh man you caught me up on that one too
it's i want to remember so hard i can't
remember uh
the name of the group though but
definitely the the people who you name
it are still people who i listen to like
like ritz and stuff like that
now hey by the way ritz you and rich
ever talk about doing the ep together
yeah okay okay okay because he's he's
mentioned that too that's my boy so he
had mentioned to that
in passing and i was like hey you that'd
be crazy
yeah yeah yeah we mentioned it it's
gonna happen it's gonna happen we're
gonna be in the right space at the right
time
he's also another one of those guys that
raps very fast but like
enunciates his words so where it's just
like
if you're listening you understand every
single thing he's saying
yeah you know like you some some some
people got a funk zone with it and then
some people
you know they just do it you know you
got to have a funk zone with it you know
i wanted to so so um your boy had sent
me some talking points and i had no idea
that you a group that that
that it'll come to me okay okay so i
didn't know that you
are a concealed gun carry instructor
yeah concealed carrier so official
certified uscca and nra concealed carry
instructor
yeah and you started a new gun safety
company called the gun camp
yeah this is in chicago yeah so
i'm cause i'm a proponent i'm a pretty
liberal dude but i'm very
very you know i feel like we should all
have a right to protect ourselves
what i'm saying um how did you get
involved in
in that because i would never in my
wildest dreams picture you know
man like i've always been into firearms
but then when i got my concealed carry
my boy
eddie trained me uh to get my concealed
carry license
and then when i wanted to be an
instructor my boy creative can train me
uh my uh creative trained me to be a
concealed carry instructor
really during that whole quarantine you
know
so i think a lot of us got an extra
career or
in the quarantine around that quarantine
thing so
you know what happened with with me was
i got into
that whole industry very heavy you know
and became an instructor
and just you know just been going after
a lot of certification since then
a few extra ones you know so um that's
something i'm into
heavy i'm an advocate for um second
amendment
yeah definitely i want to uh i want to
teach people the right way
when it comes to course guns and gun
safety and
yeah you know just that people's thought
process about guns
yeah i think that um sometimes in
hip-hop we get like a little like
wrapped up in like uh whatever
the popular issue is at the time and you
know i always talk with killer mike
about this because killer mike's
also a very pro second amendment he's
gotten a lot of [ __ ] for that by the way
like that came came for him a lot but i
think that
uh you know especially in l.a it's crazy
no they've came for mike a lot yeah i
know that and it's
it's wild it's like it doesn't make any
sense
and you know i think that um he would
always say like our our people
more than anybody we need to protect
ourselves more than anybody you know
what i'm saying yeah
especially with what's been going on in
the world the last you know with this
trump [ __ ] and all this other wild [ __ ]
like you never know
but it's never know what can happen but
like we live in like i live in
california and it's like out here they
pretty much make it
as impossible as possible for you to
protect yourself
so it's like out here [ __ ] is
getting robbed
shit's i i'm from phoenix though
in phoenix is anybody could have a gun
yeah but you can't have a negligent
discharge in phoenix you get
it's rough ain't it right what you mean
i think in uh arizona if you you have a
negligent discharge it's a little rough
you know you just fire the gun with that
yeah with that type of law i just know
that you're a mistake like that
i know there like i could literally give
you my gun
and that's you it's your gun now you
don't have to worry about registering it
you don't you mean like cass is really
it's the wild wild west do that in
chicago
no i'm sure i'm sure right two cards
well i was going to say there's got
it's like two sides of the coin because
if we think of chicago and the gun
violence in chicago right like
you know obviously people are going to
get guns no matter what
right yeah that that pretty much says it
like
like no matter how the gun laws are
different
in each state you still got violence
yeah and the people who are
who want those guns who are committing
those crimes they're going to get those
guns
i don't get them no matter what so why
not be protected
like why not be protected legally
obviously you know what i'm saying
what they say uh the only thing that
stops a bad guy with a gun is a good guy
with a gun
ain't that the truth ain't that the
truth
yeah it's a very it's just i just think
you know it's interesting like i think
more more people like yourself and mike
should like you know
i think it's dope that you guys talk
about that because in hip hop you know
and i'm a like i said i'm pretty much
liberal on
most things just the gun [ __ ] i'm like
listen man like
this was america for a reason yeah yeah
you know it's in the it's in the
constitution that we could protect
ourselves
yeah you know what i mean and it is what
it is and you know
a lot of times we we you know we are
conditioned
to have a perception of guns that make
you go oh
you know what everybody else going so
your
your thing is is to try to just educate
people like yo like this is
you know cause because gun's a scary
thing you know what i'm saying so
when you do these courses you're
teaching people about the weapon you're
teaching people how to
take it apart put it back like what yeah
we're teaching
all of that we're teaching people how to
break a gun down put it back together
like you know a field strip so you can
clean it and everything
the parts to a gun how to hold the gun
proper stance
proper grip the uh uh safety rules
you know how to keep your finger off the
trigger you know how to make sure you
don't muzzle anybody the whole
everything so so not only just the
mentality of having a gun but
how to properly uh care for a gun
and handle it with safety so you said
during the during the pandemic you pick
that up
because i know you do a lot of live
shows like i know that you like
under normal circumstances you do a
bunch of live shows every year how many
live shows would you say do a year
i don't know that's a a a question for
somebody else
but a lot but a lot yeah cause i know
you're in phoenix a lot you know my
homie justice books you out there shout
out to justice
but um but uh what did you like like
outside of learning this new this new
trade would it
how else did you handle the pandemic
because the [ __ ] was kind of
you know at first it was kind of like
i feel like the first couple months it
felt like
oh well i could work from home yeah i
feel like i do a lot
i drew a lot of portraits and stuff like
that
you know really yeah that was actually
the first thing
that i did as a kid you know so you were
always a good artist first talent that
popped out was me drawing yeah so
so he was whipping up some portraits
during the pandemic yeah i was
you know drawing portraits did you watch
uh the tiger
what's the guy's name tiger king did you
watch tiger king on netflix
nah oh you didn't watch that you heard
of that though i heard of it yeah this
[ __ ] was great i just i
know it didn't grab me i wasn't you know
it wasn't a
time frame where it grabbed me enough to
say let me watch this yo
have to stop the bootleg podcast real
quick and shout out our sponsor odd
socks
that's right they've been holding us
down from the jump man and they're
not only the makers of the most
comfortable socks in the world shout out
to odd socks
but they also now got the draws man the
boxer briefs are so
fire they're so soft they feel great on
your ass your nuts
whatever you're into you know what i'm
saying whatever you got they'll cover
them up real real comfortably
and ladies you know you could wear these
things to sleep so go to
oddssocksofficial.com
use the keyword bootleg kev save 20 off
you know one of the licenses they just
got that i love
are the naruto socks they just got the
naruto socks
of course they got wwe those are mankind
socks ladies and gentlemen
spongebob and shout out to the the goat
ric flair so what you got to do get you
some odd socks
thank me later save 20 off at checkout
by using the keyword bootleg kev
odd socksofficial.com and we are
super proud that they're presenting this
podcast let's get back to it what are
your thoughts on um
on you know chicago's music scene the
last eight years nine years with the
drill [ __ ]
because this the drill the drill so
when it first came out for me i i really
wasn't cause i'm like
i love the lyrical [ __ ] you know what i
mean like it was just
it it it was it wasn't for me i mean i
loved it you know a lot of people have
different different perceptions of music
at different times so at that time
me listening to the music it's a lot of
different reasons like you can listen to
some of the drill music
and you'll see like damn from a dj
perspective adrenaline rush fits right
on top of it
right right same bpm yeah yeah so
definitely i'm locked in from that
perspective then i i saw too
as technology advanced and people got a
chance to open their laptops and see
how chicago really was from a chief
keith perspective and
little dirk and all of these guys right
here that's coming up doing their thing
and you're like wow
you know so now you got something new
that you never saw
that ad now we got another element added
on to hip hop
with this old dream oh for sure real
vibe and it and it and it kind of
shifted
the way everybody is doing that music so
i love that because
you know like not only was i waiting on
chicago to just
come with that constant quality music
man once they started lighting it up man
i was like you know yeah i feel like big
fan whatever
whatever you want to say man like all is
influenced everything going on right now
like we just were in new york
interviewing all the brooklyn drill
rappers
and it was like all of them are just
straight yo i grew up listening to chief
keef
and dirk and g herbo and
yeah and all those guys too like shout
out to dirk shout out to g herbo like
those guys have evolved musically too
yeah that's right
yeah yeah and their talents have evolved
the young bulls they be killing it man i
love it
you love it what else um out of chicago
are you checking
like cuz you know like i said there's
the other side of chicago you know
there's guys like vic mensah
i mean obviously chance has been on a
quite a run since about 2013 you know
like like yeah
vic spencer too it's a guy named vic
spencer in chicago that'd be killing it
too
really yeah vic spencer i thought you
said vic spencer like
vic spencer no chicago slang vic spencer
yeah yo what's going on with uh with the
crucial conflict guys man i i
the last time i heard um i heard uh
i want to say it was was a wild style or
one of them dudes was on uh vic mensah
was a part of a group
called the kids these days and then
and they redid hey okay and i think the
dude was on and i was like yo i just i
love the final check they they still do
final tick was my [ __ ] yeah and they
still perform those records man you
you you definitely need to check out a a
crucial conflict show
one of the guys names is wild style was
one of his name was it never
yeah never i'm trying to remember if i
remember how style never cole hard
cole hart and kilo kilo yeah that [ __ ]
and that showdown record
yeah yeah that was a
tell you that album was a challenge
crucial conflict you did
what's up with uh the do or die guys
still doing shows
still doing their things yeah i do a lot
of records with them you know
yeah what would you like like like you
know because because uh
there was definitely a vibe about that
music y'all were making like
uh it was some cause you know we think
of chicago
and i i remember as a kid seeing the
documentary like getting the documentary
from blockbuster that
i forget which pimpin documentary it was
but you remember they was doing pimping
documentaries in the 90s yeah
and i remember ice-t went to the players
ball in chicago
and there was like all kinds of famous
pimps
there was like mr wife i can't even
remember all the pimps in this [ __ ]
movie
but chicago is known for pimping for
that culture right yeah yeah
and that vibe and that player [ __ ] when
that pope record got made
yeah and i felt like that the some of
those records were just they kind of
just
fit that vibe and it was something it
was like it's like it
almost was like a real midwest like
at the time there was west coast there
was east coast and like the mid like
that was like to me like what i
what i kind of computed as like midwest
[ __ ] yeah i mean it was everywhere
though you you definitely had it
you know out this way you know a lot a
lot for sure shout out to the bay yeah
yeah yeah but
but so i just feel like when you when
you
input that vibe in a certain place
i think it's uh just the aura you know
or the swag
of of the whole uh pimp culture you know
more so than anything just would affect
the music in a certain way
you know 100 um you got a new project
coming out
420 yeah a joint project
yeah 420 and you know like when you were
speaking of the young bulls in chicago
definitely well let's get your man in
here so we can we can talk about it man
we want to go grab them
you're doing a joint album
that's my man relo he got some dope
music you know
in chicago we'd be doing our thing he'd
be doing his thing in the studio
you know he he'd been working in my
studio for a long time
and uh brello he'll be coming with it
all right so
420 what's that what's the name of the
album man the news at nine
news at night news at nine yeah
how long have you guys been making music
together you've been
how long you've been working in like two
years
okay you i got to figure this out
because this guy's
you've you've killed so many rappers on
so many songs
it's like embarrassing like you got you
got a hit list of guys you just put
under the dirt on their own records you
know what i'm saying
how it's never that man i don't know but
it is it's not
it might not be that on purpose yeah
yeah but come on
yeah man i pick up the energy of the of
the artists i'm working with i'm always
excited about the music and i always try
to
try to please so you yeah what kind of
pressure is it hopping on a record with
this guy
or doing the whole album let alone i
don't miss a lot of pressure but you
know i create so
i make sure the music a1 everything got
to be up to par
you know cause like you say definitely a
legend so i step in the booth i gotta
make sure i gotta
have everything in order then plus you
know see you might not be
be into his music as of yet but once you
get into his music
and see how you know how artistic and
prolific he is with it you'll see
it's not a problem for him to get on the
record if anything
in some in some ways it's reverse a lot
of times
because remember i'm i'm from a certain
era and i have to stay relevant and keep
up
and if i don't stay fresh and youthful
thinking
then i can't mesh into that whole vibe
right so if anything
i'm hearing fabulous music when i come
into the studio every day
so when i get offered the opportunity to
get on it i got to make sure
that when i'm on it i ain't coming with
something that's like man
you got my [ __ ] sounding old as hell you
you get what i'm saying so i if anything
i gotta kill it and have that same
mentality just as much
uh as he might how many records is on
this project it's five records on that
okay so five piece nice little five
people are you from chicago as well
chicago
south side okay how would you say you
described like you described where you
fit into like
like the chicago sound right now um
basically
i'm just gonna usher in a new sound
cause like you say it's a whole bunch of
drill rappers but how i'm coming i'm
telling the shorties to stay positive
create and i'm saying dream and chase
their goals so
he's trying to step outside of the drill
and just give him the real you dig
sure sure that's i mean [ __ ] city for
like
that birth common and and hey
i want to just acknowledge some of the
most influential guys
that don't get love the cool kids shout
out to chicago's on the cool man shout
out to the chuck english
yeah no those guys uh those guys have
influenced so much when it came to
fashion and sonics and music and they
they really get their credit you know
what i'm saying yeah those guys that
are super legends man so shout out to
the cool kids much love
so the album comes out on the 20th 4 20
4 20.
yeah that makes sense man well it's a
holiday
yeah big holiday definitely a holiday
yeah and it's a dope record you're gonna
like it you're gonna be surprised
any features yeah
yeah the one-two punch man yeah you're
gonna be surprised you're gonna enjoy it
you're gonna be like oh man
all right well yo ghost go go get that
and then um
are you working on any any more solo
[ __ ] to us yeah
after that we got i got a project solo
that's gonna be called shooter ready
shooter ready shooter ready yeah so that
how many records in are you on that
it's pretty much done i probably got
like one record to do just because
you know and it's like a combination
it's
flat out my original sound but it's a
combination of
what you would normally hear me do
musically me attacking
and beats and music and then you got me
you got me doing music from the
perspective
talking about guns from a perspective
that you've never heard
you used to rah-rah gun [ __ ] but i'm
talking about guns from a perspective
you never heard before
so you're talking about guns from the
perspective of a guy who teaches a gun
course now
not that
it ain't that simple right right right
right right you know but when
you know you ain't gonna hear me say
clip you're gonna hear me say magazine
okay okay okay you know but it it it's
dope you're gonna hit it
uh talk about what you're doing with the
real estate [ __ ] right now because i
think uh
the real estate market is i don't know
how it is in chicago but i don't know
everywhere else it's crazy right now
yeah i mean is that something that
you've been investing in for a while
yeah i mean uh we definitely dabble in
that area too
you know i try to hide my hands in a few
things
right now they say if you ain't got your
hands in about five
if you ain't got income coming from like
five different sources then you you
lacking you know so we definitely try to
keep busy
and things like real estate you know uh
what i do with the music
what i do as far as wait wait
the gun life hmm a bunch of things
has there ever been any talks because we
got the bad boy reunion tour
which was legendary yeah um
there's been you know so many dope like
it's kind of
has there ever been anything kicked
around about doing any sort of like
rockefeller reunion tour or show or
anything like that i mean i know the
dame j uh
relationship is obviously what it is uh
i don't i don't know but if they do it i
gotta jump down
and and and if they do another bad boy
to her i'm gonna have to send a clip of
me doing is this the end
to diddy so he can see like damn twisted
[ __ ] like yesterday
so he can be like come on in yeah come
on
you still got your rockefeller chain of
course
that's something that like that's like
history man yeah i need to bust it out
at the show or something one day or
or an occasion you know a great moment
or something
and bust it out who who actually like do
you remember the actual show where you
got the chain because i remember seeing
it
i just don't remember like like you said
it wasn't in chicago but what was the
actual
remember the actual place i was
i can't remember but i remember how the
stage looked and everything
when dame walked on stage how he gave it
to me the whole presentation and
everything so i was real geek
do you think dame gets um is like
misunderstood sometimes
because i feel like dame's i feel like
he's i feel like when i when i hear him
talk i understand what he's trying to
say
i just think sometimes he says it in a
way that
might be off-putting to certain people a
little too rough but i understand what
he's saying
i always understand what he's saying
like he's never really wrong
he just might have might say it a little
rough yeah
yeah uh i definitely think he gets uh
misunderstood a lot but if you listen to
him the right way like you said
there's nothing but gems so many gems
did you ever have a one of those like
experiences with dame where maybe he
because you know i always think back to
watching um
backstage you know the movie where he
was going off on
clue and and kevin lyles and i mean
did you ever were you ever like a
witness or a part of a go off moment
yeah no i'm glad i missed all them yeah
i wasn't around those yeah cause like i
feel like
what year did you what what year was we
are the champions was that in
2002 2001
you know you have a problem trying to
give me the guests these years to match
up these records
paid in full soundtrack pull it up
what's up yeah
okay hey when when when they sent you
that record um
we are the champions was everyone's [ __ ]
already on it were you like like
like like how did you hear it i was
actually in new york i was actually
standing in the studio with uh benny
siegel
with uh them talking about the record
with
with dame explaining to me how he wanted
it to sound and everything
and uh where did i record it
that i recorded in chicago and i can't
remember when i recorded it but i
remember
writing it um and i remember doing it in
new york you remember where i recorded
champions at
but we we got the record in new york and
i took it back to chicago that's what
happened
were you there because i always what i
loved about beanie siegel's verse on
that song
is it was really not it was just really
him it was just him talking
going off yeah like we it was it was
just like
energy it wasn't so much about his rapid
as much as it was like
yeah you know what i mean like he even
stopped rapping yeah i love that vibe he
put on there were you around like
like you said you're in with beanie when
that record got like explained was he
did he record it that night or i don't
think he recorded it that night but uh
yeah i don't think he recorded that
night but he was definitely around
and just you know the whole vibe and
everything and then
you know i was the new one to the team
so that's worse that was the energy that
i had on that record right there on the
champion oh yeah when they brought you
on when dame brought you on it was like
oh man and then you just you hit the
home run
yo who's somebody who you've recorded a
song with or that you hopped on a record
with where you were intimidated
when it came to like you know you've
worked with a lot of legends man
and like i said you've you've done your
thing on a lot of people's records and
made them look crazy but who's somebody
who you were like
extra like man i really gotta bring my
[ __ ] damn
i don't know i mean um
i love hate doing records with tec-9
ah yeah i love hate doing records with
that dude
you guys got some [ __ ] you gotta work
it's like i know he feel the same way
trust me if you ask me
if you're in a lazy mode you don't want
to do a record you got to be
ready you got you got to like miss the
[ __ ] out of rocks
i feel like tech 9 always has the
biggest chip on his shoulder what he
raps like no matter what he's like
always
it's like it's just there's a chip and
it it's just
it's it's too much going on and you guys
you were on you were on too much out
you were on the worldwide choppers with
busta rhymes yellow wolf
there was a lot of people on that record
like nine months yeah yeah i was on that
yeah like that record was
crazy like when you go back and listen
to that that was like
eight minutes straight of people just
from all over the world people from
insta
from turkey on there all kinds of it was
yeah tech nines
man tech nine is also for a lot of
artists if
if you want to come up go watch a
technology concert so you can figure out
how to perform too because that
[ __ ] is a beast live
oh yeah so who are you you got another
guy um
it's probably a bunch of them but uh i
can't think of any right now that uh let
me see who
pops right in my head of course
jay of course jay yeah um
worried or scared but but probably uh
my thought process on how i was gonna
come with my delivery or
what to do with this particular person
you know sort of like damn there's such
a such oh this so-and-so
right right you know so like mariah
somebody like that you know yeah like
damn
you know but like like another rapper or
something like that it's probably
somebody i just can't think of
anybody right now besides tech
technology
that's the wonder and probably buster
yeah
it's the work you got to put some damn
work in and you're gonna feel like all
that sometimes
for sure for sure what's your favorite
personally like what's your favorite
album of yours
um adrenaline rush
adrenaline rush that was 97 right what's
that next yeah 96. i'm over asking you
about years and [ __ ]
about about 96. adrenaline rush man i
should remember but
you know yeah i feel like that's the
album too that's also like uh you know
we don't
it's it's one of them i feel like it's
like a cult classic like my favorite
movie is called the big lebowskis right
up there
a lot of a lot of people don't talk
about the big lebowski i feel like
adrenaline rush is a cult classic like
it's like if you know you know
you know what i mean yeah you had to be
there type [ __ ] yeah that's my joint
right there man
that's that you know of course kamikaze
and my first album but
kamikaze was like your commercial peak
as far as like
hit records on an album right just like
that was like
yeah yeah i would call it my commercial
peak yeah
yeah yeah do you think what do you think
like
kind of you know because you've you've
had such a long career obviously still
doing your thing
but what do you think
worked against you kind of extending
that peak longer
um
me me loving rap from a certain angle
you don't always
love rap from a rapper's perspective and
not a
be in the industry's perspective mm-hmm
and so
sometimes some of that may have hindered
me you know
i always had the will to to want to be
half
normal half amazing or in this thing
you know so i got to have a little bit
of normal in my life and i think that
thought process
kind of you know hinders me
in and because because to be in the
industry man like
successful people outside of it don't
realize how much hard work it is it's
it's way harder than the nine to five
but they don't know that until they try
to get in it
and do it you know so so you're saying
essentially like you know
like like you said you know if you're in
the industry you got to go to functions
you got to kind of
you got to i mean you got to kind of
have fake friends
like people who you kind of talk to just
because it's a good like you know
there's associates there's a lot of um
people who you might consider
acquaintances but not friends in the
music industry right
man you gotta do you you gotta do a it's
a lot of [ __ ] and other people and
it's an extremely lot of [ __ ] in
yourself
and it's just only so much i can
[ __ ] myself you know what i mean so
i just got to keep it real i i wanted to
be a dope-ass rapper
rock shows rock people put out records
and there was a certain extent of it
you know so so to to get to a certain
level to have to act a certain way or be
a certain way
or fake a certain uh friendship with
certain people and isn't that i just
couldn't be
into on it what was um a feature that
almost happened that didn't happen for
you damn
oh i know it's gonna be one to come
right in my head quick let me think
i always think back to like just being
like a big a big fan of biggie
and thinking like i got a late one i got
a late one
first off let me say i love all rappers
in texas
i'm a fan of all rappers in texas and
with that being said i was just about to
do
a feature with mode three oh yeah
we was like probably days away right we
were literal
literally days away from working on a
record together
so he yeah he passed
was it this year was it late last year
mo 3 is dealt man he just put a new
album out too so uh that just came out
uh friday yeah all of them guys dope man
so you've always been a big fan of the
texas guys yeah all the texas got
dallas houston um yeah hey sure hey man
what was it like coming up at the same
time as common in the same city
because i that's the comment i mean i
loved resurrection and like that era of
comment like when he was common sense
like
you guys kind of being on like opposite
sounds of the sa
like of the same city like did you guys
have a good relationship in the 90s like
yeah we was always cool we never really
got a chance to like
hang around each other right as much as
we probably could have but
you know just was on different vibes you
know he was a south side
guy was the west side guy my music was
you know
more street orientated his was more
hip-hop orientated
you know were you rooting for him when
he when he when he
put out the [ __ ] in you against ice
cube oh yeah ooh
man that was bad right that was cool i
knew what was gonna happen
you know but damn i know it was gonna
happen like that oh smooth as it
happened
yeah i think cube itself even respected
it i i wilded out when i saw cube too
man i
had a fan out moment of course yeah like
damn
there's a few of those guys [ __ ] i mean
i i it's crazy because you know
losing dmx i was one of the few guys in
hip-hop i met who i like really was like
star struck i had to like tell him like
man you understand what you meant to me
bro like you know what i'm saying like
yeah i saw him at an award show
and i fanned out and didn't speak to him
he was walking past so he didn't really
see me
and i had the opportunity to probably
speak to him but i just looked and
fanned out
and because of the current situation
that that's one moment i regret that i
didn't
go straight at him oh you said my dmx
yeah yeah
yeah it's crazy man yeah hey you know
he lived a good life you know he there
was an interview clip that i saw uh
recently on the
drink champs where he said if i drop
dead tomorrow i lived a good life and he
did live a good life man yeah touched a
lot of people
rest in peace to dmx well look the new
album is out 420
yeah ep and then a new twist album will
be coming
shortly after as you said it's pretty
much done yep 4
20 we got news at nine with reload the
dreamer right here with you
shot down and then we got shooter ready
that's coming after that
we got a bunch of dope songs you're
going it's like a mixture of adrenaline
rush
and shooter features on that
oh yeah it's it's a few surprises on
there okay i didn't go
too hard with the features it's a few
surprises i kept it uh
adrenaline rush-esque do you enjoy being
independent now
like as opposed to the major label [ __ ]
yeah i've always enjoyed it once i got
into it you know
yeah when we first started off we was
killing it too right
yeah it's always like you know it's it's
i think nowadays specifically
back in the day would make sense
assigned to a major label yeah i think
once you learn
learn the ropes a little bit learn the
business got people on your team that
can kind of uh
emulate what you would get from a record
label and especially got some income
well yeah now i feel like nowadays you
get there's you go straight to the fans
back in the day you kind of needed a
label to get
to your fans yeah because there's no
internet it's like yeah
it's like so technology was expensive
then
yeah now it's free labels they had the
money to do it
right now technology advanced to the
level where
you know it can't be controlled like
that and and
you know in one way so i think a lot of
artists today got an advantage
you know the advantage today is that you
can
use technology in a way that we couldn't
in the past
the other difference though is that
the the playing field you got so many
people
to be up against that also have the
internet for free
got you so it kind of balances itself
out when you have the og's like
oh y'all got it easier than us cause we
not really because right right
new cat's got to go against a million
other people yeah when you were probably
the only person rapping in your
neighborhood
right because now everyone's rapping
everyone can get fruity loops everyone
can go
buy a mic for a hundred dollars or so so
it evens itself out
yeah it's like they got their little
perception the gift and the curses of
each era
even themselves out yeah for sure
because like now you got like you said
it's the
everything's so saturated it's like it's
like djing
you know back in the day you had to buy
records you had to learn how to actually
mix you know now you got a laptop you
download some songs
yeah you get a little controller and you
go do a gig
back in the day was not like that would
not you know you can literally play a
video
of a dj's old dj set
right your party that [ __ ] crazy well
look twisted thank you for coming
through man the legend twister
uh go get your new new project
appreciate you coming through
man let's get to it boom perfect much
love y'all